아네 안녕하세요 괴상함입니다
인트로를 찍기 위해서
헬기까지 타려고
헬기장에 나와 있습니다 제가 사실 그
바이킹도 못하는데
멋진 뉴욕 인트로를 위해서
목숨을 걸고
왔습니다 잘 타고 올게요
[음악]
어 지금 가시는 곳이 이제
47 세일막스 플레이스라고
다운타운에서 약간 리스트 쪽에 위치해
있어요
청년대 2000년대 초반까지 약간
일본
타운이었어요 거기 가면은 이제 뭐
일본 야끼두리집부터 시작해서 스시집
되게 많았는데
일본 친구들이 거기를
떠나기 시작하면서 약간 아이덴티티를
잃었어요 여기가 8가를 지금
서쪽에서 동쪽으로 가로질러서 가고
있는 있는데 이제 여기가 브로드예요
브로드웨이를 지나면 이제 아까 제가
말씀드렸던 일본 하온 같은 곳들을
보실 수 있을 거예요 누누이
말씀드렸던 것처럼 이제 웨스트가 조금
더 이렇게
활성화되어 있다고 말씀드렸잖아요
이스트에서도 이쪽 동네가
그래도 이스트에서는 좀
활발한
상권이 좀 잘 되어 있는
여기서부터죠
이렇게 상권이 죽다 보니까 이거를
사서 리디벨롭을 하는 거죠 여기도 다
일본 가격이었어요
전통 일본 가게였는데 지금은 사실은
색깔이 너무 너무 좋아요
제가 오늘은
뉴욕의 진짜 빌딩을 좀 보러 왔는데
저희 빌딩을 소개해주실 박진우
부사장님이랑 저희 스티븐을 좀
모셨습니다 안녕하세요 바이오께서
2021년에 매입하셨고 전체를 완전히
안에까지 싹 다 레노베이션을 한
빌딩입니다 전기부터 시작해서 뭐
인테리어 전부 다 이제 레노베이션을
했고 지금 10개 은행 중에 6개
유닛이 임대가 돼 있습니다 지금
지출과 렌팅
컴을 해서 noi가 나오면 지금
에스킹하는 1300m 달러에 수익률은
1년에 5.5%가 조금 넘습니다 여기
지금 상권은 지금 좀 어떤지
까지 지금 좀 본격적으로 안에 가서
좀 보도록 하시죠
여기
[음악]
방 하나
방 하나가 있잖아요
[음악]
완전히 이제 자기들만의 프라이빗한게
있고 여기서는 이제 공용공간으로
주방을 쓸 수 있으니까 그런 부분은
다만 화장실에 하나라는게 조금
에스킹은
죄송합니다 6,950 불이네요 근데
다른 유닛들이
7050불에 이제
에스킹을 이거는 프로포머라고 오너가
렌트를 산정을 해 놓은 거예요
근데 실질적으로 렌트 된 유닛들을
보면 여기 7050불에 예상을 했는데
7,500불에 임대가 됐고요 그래서
조금씩 이제 맨하탄의
임대시장이 좀 좋아졌다 보니까
프로포마 보다는 조금 더 렌트가 더
올라갑니다
동네가
교통 편하고
학생분들은 이제 캠퍼스 가기도 편하고
또 이제 행아웃 하는 장소도 많이
있으니까 사실 이런 거는 학생분들이
와서
혹은 뭐 좀 이렇게 젊은 직장인
분들이 와서 룸메이트 하면서 살 수
있는 그런 전형적인 유닛이 아닌가
싶어요
[음악]
아 여기는 여기가 좀 더는 안 돼요
5층까지 걸어 올라가야 되는 그런
있겠지만
[음악]
하늘을 볼 수 있는
거를
센터에 상층부가 보입니다 저는 요층이
제일 마음에 들어요 만약에 제가
학생이라고 하면은
그래서 이거는 오프 더 레코드지만
이런 빌딩을 한국에서 사셔서
중장기적으로 안정적으로 보유하시면서
운영하실 수 있는 좀 그런 빌딩으로
저는 보여요
리테일 테넌트가 있어서 되게 좀
공실이 나면 채우기 어렵거나 그런
빌딩은 사실 한국에 계신 분들은 되게
어려워하세요
근데 주거는 사실은
임대 맞추기가 나쁘지가
맨하탄의 빌딩이 텍스들이 많이
올라가는 빌딩들이 있어요
근데 여기는 2ba는 이제
레지던셜 유닛으로만 구성된 빌딩을
텍스트 클래스 2a에 들어가는데 여러
가지 좀 조건들이 있긴 해요
근데 그 범주 안에 들어가기 때문에
1년에
맥스로 올라간다고 하더라도 부동산세가
5% 이상 오르지 않고요
5년에 또 이제 그 이상 오르지
않게끔
법 정해진 거기 때문에 예상하지
못했던 익스펜서가 갑자기 발생해서
손해가 날 수 있는 빌딩은 아니라는
거 그리고
계속 우리가 이야기 나눴던 대로
애너의 학생들이라든지 젊은 직장인들이
많이 밀집해 있는 지역이다 보니까
임대하기가 쉽고 1년에
투자금 대비 5% 6%의 수익을
꾸준하게 낼 수 있는 그런 안정적인
빌딩이다라고 설명을 해주셨어요 일단
요게 지금
매입가가 지금 아이스킹 하고 있는
가격에 떨치는 밀리언 1,300만 불
저도 일단은 뭐 일단 위치가 너무
좋은 거 같고 그리고 이제 렌트비가
워낙 높다 보니까 수익성이 그래도
진짜 너무 잘 나오는 거 같습니다
그리고 렌트는 제가 부동산에 관련돼서
일하는 사람이기 때문에 말씀드리는게
아니라
인플레이션의 여러 가지
인자들이 있잖아요
근데 되게 스티키한 아이템 중에
하나예요 렌트가 한번 오르는데
갑자기 막 10%씩 떨어지거나
그러지는 않거든요
임금이랑 렌트는 사실은 되게
스티키해서 이렇게 쉽게 떨어지지
않습니다 또 세계 적으로 좀 많은
사람들이 또 유입되고 있으니까
그래도 뭐 주거에 대한 임대 시장들도
되게 좀 안정하게 유지되지 않을까
그렇게 예상하고 있습니다 제가 봤을
때 맨하탄 부동산은 입지가 제일
중요한 거 같아요네
영상 여기까지 하고요
다음 시간에도 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다
[음악]